so obviously the cannon is made up of
those books that have had the most
influence and so they're the most
fundamental whether you agree with them
or not is beside the point you need to
know them because they're at the bottom
of your culture and that's you Jordan
Peterson welcome to AEI thank you nice
to see you it's just so nice to find a
fellow traveler like God I like I
started out years ago with Camille
Paglia you know we've been fighting this
battle but we have stronger and stronger
allies we've got you and it's amazing
and when I hear you talk about topics
that have concerned me for years I mean
the politicization of the curriculum
you know the madness that's taken over
feminism and think you're making any
progress I don't know I get worried
because if twenty years ago or more when
Camille and I fought the first culture
war we thought we won and we did in
puttin in the you know court of public
opinion but they assumed the assistant
professorship s-- mm-hmm so they've been
the teachers they're in the schools of
Education and yeah they're certainly in
the schools of Education that's for sure
and so sometimes I feel like just common
sense
open discussion debate it's all
imperiled and and when you say so
sometimes people think you're a crank or
you're overstating it and and I have a
lot of self-doubt so I think well maybe
I am mm-hmm and then it's not easy to
tell him well then the James d'amour
happens you know he gets fired for for
saying what was true what was true and
and what has been increasingly
documented as true since he got fired
right by huge scales what everybody says
and knows but now it's apparently
dangerous to state the obvious
given the current orthodoxies so to me
it's just been wonderful that you have
found a way around it it's not that you
were able to defeat what was going on in
the university because you had a maybe
accidentally just this insane encounter
when you were told how you had to speak
and you protested
but now you've taken another path and
you're reaching millions of people
through your videos and then you know
the lectures and videos of lectures and
I'm just wondering if that's not the
future of Education is a kind of
alternative learning system well it's it
I think it's the present of education to
some degree I mean because people you
can find out about anything you want on
YouTube now it's it's a bit there's
there's part of it that's a bit anarchic
let's say because there are more profits
well that's it that's it that's the
thing it's not that easy to distinguish
between valid and invalid information I
mean when we when we had more reliable
gatekeepers in place let's say back in
the heyday of journalism when Time
magazine was still you know 3/8 of an
inch thick and 90% print then there was
some consensus on what constituted
reliable and valid information and
YouTube you can learn anything about
anything and maybe that's not exactly
optimal but I think it's reasonable to
have faith in people's ability to sift
through the chaff and get to the wheat
and so maybe it's a good thing overall I
mean I do think it you know in the
future people look back and say oh well
that was an arc it can you know he's
amazing anybody got in a you know
education but I think people are just
earning I don't think it's an accident
that you sort of rose to the top I mean
I even I accidentally happened upon one
of your videos and it's just amazing Wow
he's making so much sense and you
weren't at the time you weren't
addressing culture war issues and
feminism but but maybe post-modernism
and some related issues and I found you
on YouTube and then started following
you and I find even if I look at the
comments and I've looked at the comments
on your videos I have a lot of very
smart followers the comments are are
civil mm-hmm I think I've some maybe you
have better but I think I have some of
the most intelligent comments on YouTube
on YouTube yeah well YouTube can be
quite to hell
quite quite the hell of comments but I
don't get them no and most of the
comments on my youtube videos are civil
and reasonable because
have to listen and you know it takes
patience and attention so I think the
trolls are just you know interests yeah
could be well and you know they just on
this tour that I've been doing one of
the things that that that makes me
optimistic is the fact that I'm
presenting I would say difficult
material and in a relatively difficult
way it certainly I would say it's an
intellectually challenging as I can
manage and it's also emotionally
challenging and there's an immense
public demand for it and there's an
immense public hunger for long-form
discussions of the type that no one
thought a television audience so to
speak was capable of engaging in so I
have a sneaking suspicion that people
are a lot smarter than our previous
communication technologies revealed and
you know people are listening to
podcasts like mad - and lengthy ones and
audio book sales are spiking because it
looks like more people can listen than
can read and so that all that's the
positive end of the social media
explosion I would say the video and the
podcast and in particular yes and people
are what amazes me is when I hear I'll
listen to tapes you know of your
lectures with with Sam Harris or I don't
know the other day you would you with
Dave Rubin and I'm bench bureau in bed
Shapiro and you do a little bit of
politics but then it's on to Maimonides
and you know the the Christian
theologians versus the you know the
Talmud actors it's very intellectual and
and that got that's got a million views
and some already in a few it me just
instantly yeah and I found I couldn't
stop listening and in some of what you
do reminds me of this is the the delight
in college courses before the curriculum
became race class gender you know in the
humanities at NYU and the I don't want
to say late 60s it was the late 60s I
took courses with the professor Jim
Carson and we would read Viktor Frankl
and Mircea Eliade Hey and Paul Tillich
and bars and the existentialist and
it was it was so stimulating and it was
so thought-provoking and and wonderful
and the class and he was a great teacher
and it seems like that's not there
anymore like it was everybody that was
interested in ideas could have a
semester I mean now if you take
philosophy it's a little arid and
analytic but there was the philosophy of
religion and there was the religion
department where you could have that and
his courses were so popular teaching
these writers yep
they he could have enrolled the entire
school and I just thought okay that's
what that's what well you know one of
the advantages to some degree I've
thought about this is that as the
universities abandon the classical
humanities they leave that material
around for anyone else to back up yeah
well that's at its old you know it's
what there's a rule that I wrote from 12
rules for life was derived from an
original list of 42 rules that I put on
Quora and one of them was opportunity
exists where responsibility has been
abdicated and I think that's really the
case it's like maybe the post modernists
are right and the classic humanities the
Western Canon has no value it's only
arbitrary it's like so fine they can
abandon it well if it has no value it'll
disappear if it has value then other
people will find the value and start to
capitalize on it let's say in terms of
ability to attract audiences and and the
works of art will fight for themselves
because people read them to read you
know Henry James or to read you know
some forgotten author then you know
they're not assigning I've just been
reading Saul Bellow he was just so good
hmm
and I know these people were actually
good I mean I have people all the time
now who come up to me and thank me
because they've started to read great
literature but often they've started
with Dostoyevsky because I'm such a
Dostoevsky fan and you know they're just
completely knocked over by wile by crime
and punishment which is a book that will
definitely knock you over I'm afraid to
read again it knocked me over him and as
in probably responsible for me becoming
so interested in philosophy and 11th
grade we had it with miss Sullivan and
Wow it was powerful
yeah I'm now I prefer you know Tolstoy
mm-hmm and I told my friend she said
well Jost
he's 44 teenagers and tolstoy weird dude
but you don't agree hmm well I don't
know I mean I have read a couple of the
books of Dostoyevsky's books the second
time and I would say they didn't have
the same impact the second time but but
I think that's also partly because they
had such an impact the first time right
you know and so and Tolstoy is more
sociological in orientation and you know
maybe that is something that's more
interesting in some sense as you as you
get older it's it's hard for me to say I
always preferred Dostoyevsky to tolstoy
because I'm more psychologically minded
but I'm not the idiot when I read that I
mean not recently but more recently and
so I'm gonna give Dostoevsky more of a
chance but but what you say is so
important and I think it was and rag'd
said that everything important to say
has been said but nobody's listening so
you have to say it again and again and
again and that's how I feel that I'm I
feel like I have to introduce college
audiences to the you know Western
political you know classical liberal
tradition they may they may not have
been acquainted right the arguments for
free speech and duper it's very very
likely very likely they're painted but
very little yeah well a doubt and that
is a real opportunity because those
things are actually unbelievably
exciting if you if you can get into the
spirit of them you know and so that's
something that I'm hoping to do a lot
more of in the upcoming years is to
revitalize some of the fundamental
classics of the Western Canon I've also
thought about the idea of the Canon you
know because that's come under criticism
and and my I have a couple of associates
so we're working with me on an edge
online education system and we've been
trying to define what constitutes the
Canon technically and you can actually
do that we don't have to argue about
what the Canon is because you imagine
that you could rank order books in terms
of the number of other books that
they've influenced so obviously the
Canon is made up of those books that
have had the most influence and so
they're the most fundamental whether you
agree with them or not is beside the
point you need to know them because
they're at the bottom of your culture
and that's you and that's see I mean
that's what the so
funny because it's what the social
constructionist claim your product of
your culture it's like well then you
should probably know it's fundamental
writings since they make up a huge part
of your being and you should know
something about a conversation that has
been taking place among geniuses
creative geniuses over the centuries
with one another mm-hmm and how else
you'd want to listen to of course and I
always felt that I was just giving my
students this gift if they could sort of
listen here right and help them you know
approach it and then suddenly oh no you
know we're not teaching that anymore and
it's but I'm still hopeful that well I
think that statement you made you know
that that great art will speak for
itself will fart oh yeah I think that's
that I think that's right keep having
secret meetings of the introductional
darkweb oh but we haven't had any it's
not a very good conspiracy it's like
herding cats under mania but I think the
success of it is owed not because we
feel like we're oppressed and we have to
speak in the dark but because I think
we'd give voice to ideas that many
people thought themselves but maybe
didn't feel confident to say I think
there's a difference - between being
oppressed and being attacked by a
minority like you know I certainly don't
feel oppressed I have more media reach
than I know what to do with and and most
of what I've experienced from people has
been overwhelming support there's a
minority of noisy journalists there's
some snarky journalist some kids on
University campuses that are deluded by
their idiot professors but other than
that it's been and I shouldn't minimize
that because I was under quite a lot of
stress for the first year and a half or
so that this all took place but most of
the consequence of that has been
extraordinarily positive to come here
and talk to you so that's a good oh it's
nice finally to be able to sit down and
talk with you so thank you so much for
coming to AEI I hope you come back and
I'll meet you out there the IDW great
great very nice to see you hey everyone
that's the end of our discussion with
Jordan Peterson thanks for watching and
if you enjoyed what you saw remember to
like the video or leave us a
comment and be sure to check out the
rest of our videos and the research from
AEI